it's absolutely true that I led a wild
childhood I mean I guess it started at
age six when I when I tore the the
locomotive for this electric trains that
I just gotten for Christmas apart to get
the electric motor out and I think my my
parents didn't scold me I think my
father was quite fascinated with my
fascination and as time went on I he was
a physician in town and his patients
would obviously give him things to give
to me so I was one of five children I
don't know if they all got quite that
much attention but but you know he you
know some of these things like a box of
of parts from the telephone company and
a box of magnets and stuff like this and
and i just found all of this stuff so
fascinating and there was once an
explosion that you came running up with
oh yo well this was uh you know i can't
remember who told me you could buy
calcium carbide at hardware stores you
the idea was to put it in moles runways
and the generates settling gasps when
when the calcium carbide gets in contact
with water and that would sort of drive
out the moles it but but you could take
a soda pop bottle fill it mostly full of
water drop in one of these grains of
silicon calcium carbide and then jam a
rubber stopper with a with a glass tube
with it that was pulled to a fine point
so there was just very small orifice and
then you'd have to wait until all the
oxygen was out of the bottle and then
you would like this and you get this is
intense white flame and this is
essentially a miner's lamp it was fun
but it would go for I don't know a
minute or something or less and then
that you'd have to open it up and put
another one in and so I thought I would
make one kind of differently that would
run for hours so I took a 500 milliliter
beaker and filled it full of calcium
carbide and then put a had a long
beurette so there was a so it would drip
a water into this thing and then there
was
a delivery tube and and I didn't think
about the fact that there was such a
much larger volume in this thing so I I
waited what seemed like a proprietary
adumbrate than this this brilliant white
flame and I instinctively knew enough to
move my head like this this thing blew
up I went went like this and it blew up
and I had glass on the side of my face
which would have gone in my eye if I
hadn't been luckier and and so my mother
was up fixing dinner and she hears this
explosion downstairs and she comes to
the top of the stairs I was in the
basement and and so I'm coming up the
stairs cupping my hands to keep the
blood from dripping on the carpet and I
was so famous for practical jokes that
she of course couldn't trust anything I
did so she says if you're kidding i'll
kill you though I I was old enough to
drive and I drove myself down to my
father's office and he sewed up the
largest of the cuts and this had
happened so many times before